no need to apply social distancing rules
to this particular down instrument
resident but the health secretary
cleared that all our efforts to keep our
distance during the lockdown are finally
paying off it is making a difference we
are at the peak but before we relax any
social distancing rules or make changes
to them we have set out the five tests
that have to be mapped first that the
NHS can continue to cope second that the
operational challenges have been met
third that the daily death rate falls
sustainably and consistently fourth that
the rate of infection is decreasing and
most importantly fifth that there is no
risk of a second peak the NHS coping
with huge numbers of patients but
problems still on making sure their
staff have the right protective kit this
consignment finally arriving from Turkey
overnight it was due on Sunday I make no
bones about it there have been
challenges there still are challenges
we're not there yet
I missed a global shortage in personal
protective equipment we've distributed
over a billion items to the frontline
where it's needed most and I'm on the
phone every day pursuing the next batch
of deliveries from abroad PPE a
logistics problem bigger strategic
questions on the horizon now to the
health secretary said today we've
reached the peak of the crisis is this
the light at the end of the tunnel that
we have been talking about and waiting
for so there's certainly light at the
end of the tunnel there is a glimmer and
we're coming through the peak but we're
not there yet
politicians reluctant to level with the
public about what life after the peak
might look like the chief medical
officer more forthcoming
we have to be very realistic that if
people are hoping that it's suddenly
going to move from where we are now in
lockdown suddenly into everything's gone
that is a wholly unrealistic expectation
we're going to have to do a lot of
things for really quite a long period of
time and on PPE honest about the
challenges and earnest in his concern
for NHS staff NHS workers just want to
know they have the equipment they need
when they turn up
work can you tell me when you expect the
shortages to be resolved it is very
clear that at the moment we are tight at
different times for different items of
PPE so at this point in time we are
still close to the line but at a
national level we're not underwater on
anything that I'm aware of this
manufacture one of thousands who believe
they have something to offer we might be
able to mobilize a million to two
million square meters per month and that
could be five to seven hundred thousand
gallons per month what we've done is
we've actually purchased as much viral
barrier film as we could we've flown it
in a great expense into the UK and we've
made that solely available to the NHS we
have no orders given at the moment
you're trying to hold back the supplies
for the NHS but the government haven't
contacted you there's an execution issue
here isn't that yes there is no
execution issue I think the I think the
issue is the government has relied
heavily on importing P P government's
PPE problem is a priority now but this
Christ is moving to another phase soon
nearly a month into lockdown and the
peak has arrived it's not the beginning
of the end of this crisis but it could
be the end of the beginning
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster